are you tired of viruses spam complying
with the law then you need DC Matic the
government email server you keep at the
house DC Matic helps protect against
annoying viruses like heartbleed Stuxnet
and the American people here's how it
works first select some government
business you'd like to conceal from the
public then simply use DC Mattox
proprietary privacy control to make sure
it's gone forever is this illegal it's
not not illegal having two email
addresses and confusing two terrible
it'd be like having two batch on the
rest but don't take my word for it
listen to this testimonial hello
Oversight Committee did you receive the
entirety in the emails I sent during my
four years at the State Department you
received them both great thanks the
semantics gone are the days of creating
fake email alias ISM destroying hard
drives what that's that's currently
happening but wait there's more order in
the next ten minutes and we'll also
include this free pamphlet of press
conference tips I thought using one
device would be simpler and obviously it
hasn't worked out that way
DC Maddock when your ideas are so good
you don't want voters to know what they
are
order today